he is beloved and hysterical Martin
Short ladies
[Applause]
to deserve this kind of a patient other
than provide decades of quality
Entertain You
hello so reluctant to basket love with
you love show business that's why I do
love shoes and you're not afraid to say
it and or you like your characters well
you think Jackie Rogers jr. oh like
their show business people yes in your
blood it is in my blood is it not in
your blood you always wanted to be in
show business
um whose show is it okay someone's gonna
ask something we're fighting already
no we are we have so Michaels friends
you know we have so much in common I
told you that the last time after I read
your memoir yeah like the the father who
didn't eat dinner with us yes right the
squabbling Irish family absolutely
comedy that the you know the problem
with the large penis all these things
you know what else I found reading your
new thing we are both people who don't
have a bucket list I thought I would do
it yeah I don't either
nothing nothing I want to do that I
haven't done and if I haven't done it at
the age of 69 right I don't want to do
it right all of a Sholem you know right
right I've never been to any any country
like any country that's you know get
room service five stop
I always say nowhere where they could
take a chicken on a bus that's my butt
here 69s is a comedian when you hit that
age did you say to yourself I've got to
do something with that for the whole
year I'm 69 I can't oh come on please
I 69 iods love me it is daunting to
suddenly be 69 I mean you realize for
the first time wow you look at fantastic
it's getting up look at that hair it's
like you know for example I no longer
put an angel on top of my Christmas tree
because it feels like foreshadowing so I
always say if I wrote a memoir it would
be called who was in my body maybe just
because when I look back at things that
I do or someone reminds me of something
I did I'm like who was in my body I
can't I know that was me but I don't
know who that was when you did when you
were 25 and you go who is in my body you
know I wish I was more interesting than
that I mean it I mean I wish I could
look at pictures of me at 25 and say I
don't know who that is I mean I
basically the same I'm doing the same
thing certainly the same jokes since I
was
my whole life it's just been and I think
that's what's kept me actually young and
and involved in my life in a great
energised way because I don't see
limitations oh now that you're in your
60s you can't do no well I mean you
can't play you know 25 minutes oh I can
if you know because when you're timeless
know if they like me but you I know you
said that when you feel like up to the
age of 15 you respond you take in
everything and the rest of your life
you're just regurgitating and recycling
all of them yeah it's like me saying oh
guys I love rap yeah I love Frank
Sinatra because I like Frank know when I
was 12 and 35 into town yeah but when we
have a [ __ ] that we go through an entire
Sinatra album from that no one else no
no one else knows bright but and alone
but I think that you are the most open
to it all and you're in the most
influenced and then by the time you're
18 you're ready to do it and see what
you've learned so you're on the road
with Steve Martin how many how many
weeks a year all right how many nights
did you you've got these dates coming up
well see the show it's vintage
yeah it's it's I say our show is like
married sex we do old material three
times a month
[Laughter]
[Applause]
4550 shows and like most comedy teams
it's what you really are with them it's
great on stage but offstage you hit each
other right no I actually love Steve I
don't know I and I think that what's
great about it is that we share many
similarities in a work approach if it's
if it's an audience that we still give a
hundred so for it feel guilty all those
things but some people don't and I think
that we have a shared Sensibility it's
very rare that if a joke made him laugh
and I wouldn't very funny or vice versa
so I always think that you could be the
ambassador from Canada and maybe you
know someday you will be so I just
wanted to say Toronto last night how
about that one the NBA know pretty good
they had the basketball champ
I guess I got to go to bat for Toronto
yeah I spent a lot of time in Toronto
and Canada in general they got a little
bad rap because when Kevin Durant was
injured yeah some of them applauded it
was a moment they got caught up in the
game anybody who thinks that's Toronto
does not know Canada they won the last
night I think like two fans burned a
lady scarf one of the thing I love about
your show with with Steve you do not
mention Trump our second guest tonight
who does not mention Trump and I think
that's great because I agree you don't
always have to go there with people well
I think I do think that that we have you
know 5050 in the audience and if we if
there's an attitude from us that says
and they're not expecting it it's not
and it's not like we're political
communities and they're not expecting it
and suddenly we're putting down shrub
it's like if I'm a Republican the
audience who supports my field gee I
left out right now when I think they
there's they need a respite from this
constant and said but I also think I
said this last Thanksgiving when you go
home for Thanksgiving just don't talk
about politics we used to be able to do
that we used to be able to sit with
people who we knew was a different
political stripe and just we're watching
a baseball game we don't have to always
go there but I have friends I have lots
of friends who I don't I don't think I
know anyone
supports Trump but I I well I do I know
I actually died and right I mean I know
many many Republican friends who might
in the past we were different but you
don't discuss it you don't it's okay
you know Canadians all discuss politics
all the time and it isn't a fist Acuff's
it's just a conversation but it's it's
more cat fields McCoy's you know
you